[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Well,
this isn't something
you see every day-- a big
black sign with a rather
unusual message on the side
of a road in a place that
looks like it's in
the middle of nowhere.
"See mystery lights."
All right.
I'm curious.
What exactly does it mean?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The person who pulled over to
photograph the mysterious sign
was this guy.
JONATHAN ZEDDA: Hi.
My name is Jonathan Zedda.
I am a fine art photographer
based in Rome, Italy.
The photo was taken
in Marfa, Texas,
around January of last year.
The photo is actually
the advertisement
billboard for a hotel in Marfa.
But it was just so bold and big
compared to the desert scenery.
That immediately
attracted my attention.
I was in Texas as part of
an ongoing documentation
of the desert.
I'm very fascinated
by the desert.
It's an area that attracts me
a lot, especially image-wise.
It's just that
there's no limits.
The horizon is just so vast.
And from a photography
point of view,
it was just a beautiful place.
NARRATOR: But we're not here
to talk about the desert,
no matter how beautiful it is.
We want to know what
the mystery lights are.
JONATHAN ZEDDA: I
was just driving back
toward the city on the highway.
And that particular
sign was just there.
And nothing else was around.
So it was really easy to spot.
NARRATOR: Mystery
lights are actually
a thing here in Marfa, Texas.
They're are strange phenomena
that occur year-around
near route 67,
just east of Marfa.
The lights, also referred to
as the Marfa ghost lights,
are unexplained beams
of bright white lights
that flicker across the desert
horizon in the night sky.
Catching a glimpse of
the lights is tricky,
as sightings are reported
only 10 to 20 times per year.
But for the onlookers who have
been lucky enough to see them,
the only explanation
is that it's
some sort of paranormal
activity or UFOs.
To the skeptics, they
might just be car lights.
JONATHAN ZEDDA: There was no
lights that particular day
or during my stay in Marfa.
It was a beautiful place anyway.
The Marfa lights are just a
part of the beauty of the city
and the charm of the city.
It's a small city in
the middle of nowhere
that was kept, like, in the
'50s, sort of like time machine
or time bubble in
the '50s of America.
NARRATOR: Though the town
sits in a desolate desert
with a population
just shy of 2,000,
it's become a
popular destination
for contemporary
artists over the years.
Today, the town is more
than mystery lights.
It hosts gallery exhibitions,
art installations, festivals,
and residency
programs, making it
a rather unique and
expressive part of Texas.
NARRATOR: Not every Texan is
even aware that Marfa exists,
if not on the map.
It's just plain interesting
to visit, period.
And I don't know if you
can find anything like that
anywhere else in the States.
NARRATOR: If you
enjoyed this episode
but aren't already a
subscriber to Seeker Stories,
click here to stay up to
date on all of our latest
short documentaries.
And for another episode,
please click here to watch now.
MALE SPEAKER: The Salton
Sea is a peculiar place.
It's technically the
largest lake in California.
It's located in the hottest
desert in North America.
And it was created by accident.